Good afternoon or good evening ah My
name is Jenny kingham and I am going to
talk to you today about How to design a
health monitoring program in
laboratory mice now that is a
very important topic for me and perhaps if
I explain a little of my experience in the
science of laboratory animals ah
understand why I think this topic is so
important I am a veterinarian with
23 years of experience in
laboratory animals mainly with
genetically
modified mice I am director of the
vivariums of the Gaden Institute of Medical
Research and I have two vivariums, one  one that
is breeding and the other that is
experimental Oh and the
breeding wallet is a National supplier of
spf mice specific pathogen free mice
in Australia so I have
a great responsibility to ensure that
the mice I send Not only to my
institute but to various  institutes in
Australia are free of pathogens that
can impact the
experiments
now to begin I want to go back to the
beginning Ah why do we do monitoring
and I think that one has to design something
specifically for your vivarium Ah
because there are many ways to do
monitoring if we look  why we make the
monitor one of the most common reasons is
to demonstrate that a colony is free
of
pathogens
now that is very important for
vivariums that are
espf free of specific pathogens
because one cannot say that they are free
if monitoring is not done
but  There are also
monitoring programs specifically designed to
prevent the introduction of pathogens. If
one is importing animals,
monitoring must be done before the
vivariums enter. Programs can also be designed
to diagnose the cause of
diseases to eliminate rebound
infections or it may be that the program
monitoring is to help interpret
experimental results, sometimes when there are
somewhat strange experimental results
it is also good to do
monitoring now what determines the
program. I suppose for many it is the
cost of the program, the money that is
in the budget of the vivarium and
obviously that  It is a very very
important factor but I also believe that
ideally we should create a
monitoring program that serves
scientists, serves research and
supports scientific research so
that it comes out with valid results.
Actually, I am going to talk about four
factors to consider in the design.  not
only the cost and the type of
experiment but the type of facility
that one has and the type of animals that one
has, we talked first about the type of
facility and I already mentioned the factor of
having a facility, a vivarium that
is free of specific pathogens or
SPF yes.  If
someone says that their vivarium is free of
specific pathogens, they must have a
monitoring program. That is almost a
requirement.
Now, if they do not say that their vivarium is
free of pathogens, perhaps one does not have
to have that
program. Now I believe that if their
vivarium is a
breeding vivarium has a greater reason to do a
regular
monetary program first if one has a Bio with
mine where I send animals to different
institutes in Australia it is very
important that I can demonstrate that
these animals are free of pathogens
So I do a  monitoring four
times a year quite
extensive I also have an
experimental vivarium and now in our
experimental vivarium we have mice animals
that are in the
wallet for an average of two months
perhaps in the experiment
so since they come from a
pathogen-free vivarium they are there for a short time.  In the
experimental vivarium we do
monitoring but it is much smaller than
our
breeding vivarium. Now the type of cage is going to
influence the use of Sentinels and we are going to
talk a little more about
that later in the talk if one has
IBCs cages that are ventilated.
Individually, that limits the
transmission of
pathogens a lot. So that will influence how it is
organized, how its program is designed
and finally, if one has a vivarium or
has pieces in its vivarium that
are intended for
quarantine, that will also change the
program that  you use in our country in
Australia there is a
government requirement that for all
imported mice we have to do
monitoring for the hantavirus
Now I imagine that there are other countries that
also have their
rental requirements on the type of
moneroo let's talk a little about the type of
experiments that  occurs in your vivarium and
how that can impact your
money Well there are many articles there are
book chapters that talk about the
impact of pathogens in mice
on the elements so there is a lot of
research that will be
directly impacted if you have
pathogens So for example if  one
has
experiments that are models of colitis
in
mice. It is important to know if their
mice are free of gilic species
because that will generally increase Ah
the number of animals with colitis
Ah if one is studying
liver enzymes the presence or not
of hepatitis will
also impact on the
experiments now also the rots
is obviously going to impact a lot on
intestinal physiological experiments the type of animals is going to
also impact on the type of
monitoring they
do if one has
health problems maybe you are going to change your monoo
So if you have many
young animals with diarrhea you are going to include something
like
rotavirus because that is a common cause
of
diarrhea if you have animals mice that
are
immunodeficient you are going to have to use
hundreds
Okay and also the value of the animal can
impact the monkey in our
case we are importing  many animals
from abroad and sending animals to
mice to Australia is quite expensive.
So when they arrive at our vivarium
the mice can be worth
thousands of dollars sometimes.
So I am not going to kill these to
make the money, it will change the
samples that we can  remove from these
animals I accept that the cost of
monitoring is going to be a very
important factor so we talked a little about
the factors that can influence the
cost the number of pathogens in the area
the frequency of monitoring whether one is
using internal or
external laboratories  the types of exams in my
country for less cir olía is cheaper
than the
pca And of course the use of Sentinels
can reduce the cost of monitoring and
we will talk in more detail about some
of these
factors in a little more time in the
talk  so in summary the objective
What would be a monitoring or
optimal program I create an optimal program It is going to
give us useful results that is
profitable also not too
expensive So that is a
quite
difficult balance We talk now about the
clear key decisions in making the
design we have  We have to decide which pathogens we are going
to include in the
diagnostic panel we are going to have to decide
How often we do the
monitoring whether we use an
external or internal laboratory and the type of exam and
sample we take Those are all
key clear decisions Okay how do we decide which pathogens
are included?  included in the
panel, of course you can go to an
external laboratory and ask them what
panels they offer but also
if cost is an important factor.
Maybe you will have to decide in addition to
that if it is reduced further or if there are pathogens
that  It is important for you that they do not
appear on the panel and in my experience
most external laboratories
are willing to change their panel
so this decision is
key if one has
cost limitations I include the most
common pathogens also the ones that affect the most  the
research, as I mentioned before, if
one has
colitis studies, it would be very good to include
gicopa
and obviously if there are pathogens that
directly impact the health of the
animals, it is important to know that
these are included in the
panel
and here I give an example of four panels.
different that a laboratory
in Australia offers and to explain a little about
this
panel there are four
columns in the first one there are the
pathogens
in this one. Let's
see this panel is for
Australia and it is noted that there is
only one virus which is H viris which is  in
the
panel now if you look at the other three
panels you notice that with each one
more viruses are placed etc. a
complete panel that is here at the end Oh it has
pathogens also the cost is higher
so you have there an example of
how it goes up  the cost when one places more
pathogens we talk a little about the
frequency of
monitoring Now I don't know if you are
well aware of the
statistical tables that can be used to
decide how many animals to use in
monitoring to give the possibility of
detecting  with a
frequency of perhaps
20% incidence of the disease in your Colony with a
probability of 95 per cent.
Ah there
are statistical tables that one can Ah
see in various books articles that
can guide how many animals are used
but also the possibility of detecting
infection will depend on the frequency
of
monitoring. So if you do
monitoring four times a year you have a better
chance of
detecting  a disease that if you do
monitoring twice a year Now I gave
before an example of what I do in my
vivarium with the breeding vivarium I
do monitoring four times a year in
the experimental vivarium I do
monitoring twice a
year  Yes, if there is a rebound of an infection
or you suspect that there is an
important pathogen in your colony, I would increase
the frequency to every
month. Of course, each decision to
change the frequency will have a
consequence in terms of the
cost many times of
pathogen monitoring.  Common questions are being asked more
frequently
now one of the key decisions
when one is designing monitoring
is whether to use sentinels or not now before
discussing the advantages and
disadvantages of sentinels perhaps I
should talk about the three
main types of sentinels.
The most common would be the Sentinels that
use dirty cage substrate or
bedding as the way to transmit the
infection. Now what you see here in the
photo in the photo is our cages
and I am going to demonstrate here this is our
hundreds cage
for this side.  What the technicians do
in my vivarium is that they remove
dirty litter from the cages every week
when they are making the change from the
dirty cage to the
clean cages and they place the dirty substrate in
the centennial cage now they do not place
all of the cages in each cage.  the weeks
o The cage would be full of substrate
but for example you can make the
top cages one week, the middle ones the
other week and the bottom ones in the third
week and thus rotating the sentinels will
be exposed to the pathogens that
are in the
cages Now there are limits to that and we are going
to talk about the problems with this type
of sentinel in a moment the other type
of sentinel is a cohabitant so
you place the mouse in each cage for a
while and it will obviously change from one cage to
another  You
cannot do that if
you have Male mice and you have
a
female sentinel because of course it will produce
a female sentinel so there are limits
to the use of cohabiting Sentinels
finally with the IBCs the cages that
are individually ventilated
you can place cages that collect  the
exhaust air from the other cages And that
increases the possibility that
some respiratory pathogens will be transmitted.
As I said before, there are many
advantages in using
Sentinels. First, it is the only way to
do surgery in
immunodeficient mice. You can also
reduce the cost by using  The Sentinels And
that is a very important thing, you can
use a sentinel for many
cages Ah And that is a way to make
your
dizziness profitable but you have to take into account the
limitations of The Sentinels And that is
very very
important because the transmission of the
pathogens in those vagal
Ah It is critical
to transmit
the pathogen in that circumstance if it is
a respiratory disease many times it is not
transmitted with the fecal exes in the ic
the individually ventilated cages
this is a major problem because they
severely limit
air transmission examples of  limited transmission
are, as I said,
respiratory pathogens respiratory bacteria but
also several
viruses are transmitted very
sporadically by fecal elements
or cannot survive well outside the
animal
elus is one of the pathogens is that it
really is not transmitted well in those
fecal matter So when I  I design a
monitoring program, I am going to use The
Sentinels, certainly Ah, because they are very
important for many of the
common viruses such as hepatitis
viruses, but I am also going to use them in
combination with direct monitoring of the
animals that are in the
room.
because there are some pathogens that
will not be detected using
Sentinels now what are the advantages
disadvantages of using
internal laboratories Compared to
external laboratories first an internal laboratory
will cost less to the local many
times it has a special service to its
clients but it is not
independent  There may be
very limited diagnostic panels and the
quality control is variable, it may be
excellent. But that is not always the
case. We talk a little now about the
methodology of diagnostic tests.
Because when you are
designing your
monitoring program, you must also take into
account.  the diagnostic tests that are
going to be used now
surgery has been used now for many
many years the plum is an
excellent way to detect Especially with
viruses it is It is a history of infection
But you have to remember that it is an
active infection at this
time it can  So
if one is
trying to detect a new infection
in a colony I would use the pca or
bacteriology or parasitology instead
precisely because you cannot
detect new infections with cir
Now the great advantage of  serology is that it
is quite cheap and using the
sentinels you can use an animal to
detect infections in many
animals
pcia detect active infections also
bacteriology and parasitology
we talked a little about the types of
samples now most of you
will know what type is needed  draw blood
and send generally the soil or the
serum to the
laboratory, the
PC is a little different because one of the
recent changes is that there are many cases
that can use very diverse samples.
Fecal samples are a common sample but
skin swabs can also be used.
for external parasites fronds from the
cage itself to detect external parasites
pharynx swabs to detect
respiratory bacteria So the pcr is
a
very variable test using
variable samples bacteriology
is generally used with samples
directly from the organ where one thinks
the bacteria lives so in swabs
intestinal to detect
intestinal bacteria or tracheal lavage to
detect
respiratory bacteria parasitology
there are several ways to do that And
again many of you are going to be very
familiar with this the flotation of these
feces is one way you can also
use the tape in the anus  to detect the
sfascia Ah direct microscopy of the
skin to detect external parasites and
those are the
traditional ways to detect
parasites
just now there is more emphasis on using pca
to detect these same
parasites
now
I wanted to make a summary of the types
of samples
and how many
animals that are going to be examined. So if
one uses a
sentinel one can use one animal for 100
animals and one can combine the soil of
two mice to do the surgery
then one can make a monoo with
a sample of hundreds of animals the
PC of those feces if  one is trying
to detect, for example, the
hoba, our laboratories
only ask that losp be placed from five
different animals. It can come from five
different cages. So you can see the
fact that fewer animals are being monitored.
Of course, pca can be
used
using the fecal esses.  from a
sentinel but in the case of gilic the
transmission by the fecal scats to the
sentinels is quite poor so I
use a combination when I am
doing a moning for gicopa I use
feces from the Sentinels plus
other
animal cages of various
lines.  PC skin one can use one
rub for multiple animals and
different cages it is quite
flexible
I want to spend the last part of this talk
talking about the development of monitoring
What is new in that area because I
think it is a
pretty good time to review the
programs of  monitoring that
we have I myself reviewed I changed
my
monitoring program a lot at the beginning of the year because there are
several new things that can be used Ah
that will help to do
direct monitoring of the animals Ah first there are
farms there are the external laboratories
already offer a
variety of  pcias for various
pathogens oh and let's look at some of
these
now also the use of the multiplex flent
imun S
mfi means that one can use much
less blood to do
extensive panel monitoring and also there are many
laboratories now that are offering
international services and  I suppose in the
various
countries that is very important, not all
have laboratories that are
specialized in monitoring
laboratory animals. In
Australia we are lucky we have two
laboratories that work specifically
on that but I know that is not always
the case.
Okay,
pca and here I placed some pathogens
only a fairly extensive list could have been made of
the internal eternal parasites
for me it is super good that they were pointed
out as picular tra now it can be
detected using the pca Ah again There are
articles in recent years that
demonstrate  You can
detect internal parasites like these
more easily with the PCA than with all
the other ways of doing parasitology
that I mentioned before. It is better to do a PCA
than to do the floating tape over
the anus because it detects more
parasites, now intestinal protozoa.
can detect using PC
also for nucleus mir
mir using the p on fecal eses And
that means that one does not have to kill
the animal to detect these
protaso traditionally one had to
kill the animal and do a we Mount of
the intestinal contents to
detect the  low protozoa Ah using
microscopy
so killing the animals is not
always what one wants to do the pca
helps to do
monitoring Less
invasive
now intestinal bacteria like
e
also that is a pretty good advance
having the pca for gilco bacta you can
also do pca using  fish from
animals external parasites that is something
quite
new a skin rub
or a cage rub can be used to detect
external parasites such as
matisia
mayia again traditionally one
had to look for these animals using
microscopy and pca has been shown to
be  more effective
So the PC has increased the ability
to detect some of these
pathogens I'm going to talk about the mfi the
multiplex florescent immuno and I want to
apologize because I
couldn't I didn't know how to put this in
Spanish So I hope you understand what that
meant that's a new way  of
doing
surgery, the big advantage of this
technology is that you only need a
few drops of blood
to make a broad panel of pathogens, you
can have a
complete panel of viruses using a few drops
of blood. That means again that you
don't have to  We have to kill the animal to do
the
monitoring. For
us, we import a lot of
genetically modified mice, which
has a very great value
and when we do this, we want to make a
little monkey. We don't want to kill the batons,
so we send
our samples to a laboratory that
can use this
technology using  this technology one of
the international laboratories Oh
just last year they released a new
product called optisport that we
are using at the moment
that
can use a drop of blood
on a
cardboard card to use complete monitoring
of
surgery is something very  easy to use with a
drop of blood on the
special cardboard it can be placed in the freezer
to gather several samples to send
together the sample can be sent by
mail because it can be on the way for
many days without having problems with the
sample reduces the cost of transportation  of
the sample because you don't have to send it
with ice and obviously it has the advantage
that
direct monitoring can be done on the
animals without applying the Flat Light
so again we are using that
specifically for our animals
in the
quarantine here I give an example of a
moneto program now This
monitoring program is designed
specifically for animals in
quarantine so in our
vivarium we have two ways to import
mice one is if the mice come from
a bottero and we know that they have
important pathogens they go
directly to our dirty quarantine
and  there the embryo transfer is done. There
embryos are transferred from the dirty mice
to a clean container and that way
we remove the pathogen or
eliminate the
pathogen but in the important case
we import animals from laboratories that
have an extensive monitoring program
that are free in their monitoring.
of all the pathogens, what we
want to do is ensure that the panel
they use really demonstrates the
truth of the absence of pathogens in
the imported animals. So we do
our own monitoring and if the
animals are books of these pathogens,
in that
monitoring we can send directly
Anza to these
imported animals This example of monitoring is
what we are using in our
nursery vivarium so we take a drop of
blood and with that we make a panel of
18 viruses plus mycoplasma cacil
cles and it
is not mandatory to do this monitoring  For
animals imported to
Australia we also do a
pca, we collect these fecal matter and send it
to the laboratory to do the pca and with
that sample of
fecal matter we are a monoo of caia
spicules gilc bcta intestinal protaso
with a sample
only now we also take a
swab of fecal matter and  with that we make
a culture for intestinal bacteria for
example Ah We are looking for the presence
or presence of
manela salt among others
now this freshness
places the need to kill the
animal and take a swab of the
intestinal contents so it has to be a
fresh sample is taken  germent the animal
and when you are taking a mouse
Generally a fecal smear comes out and you
can do the swab
right there for the
respiratory bacteria what people do is an
orial
farial smear and a culture is done looking for
respiratory bacteria like
paster clepsiella things  Likewise, this
sample replaces the need to kill
the animal and take
a
tracheal wash and then we take a
skin swab that we send to the pca And that is
to detect external parasites
maia
rf So that is the monitoring panel
that we are using for our
animals in
quarantine we are already doing
direct monitoring on the animals in
quarantine and we use the sentinel
only when we import animals that
are immunodeficient if the animals
have a normal immune system
we do
direct monitoring I assume the summary of what is
new because I believe That is  The thing for
me that makes me quite excited is to be
able to use new tests to
do direct monitoring without having to
apply it. The aesia for me for
monitoring animals in quarantine is
excellent. It also helps to make a difference
in your normal animal monitoring program.
breeding For example, if one is
worried
about specific pathogens that are not
transmitted well to Los Centinelas,
a direct monitoring can be done on animals, which
is sometimes quite valuable.
Genetically
modified animals, too, many of these
new
tests require minimal intervention
because the cage sample  for
external parasites Ah it could be a
collection of those it could be a
blood leak in all these cases the
intervention in the animal is the minimum So
that gives new opportunities to
monitor valuable animals and
do
direct monitoring now we are getting
closer to the
final I think I
have I'm looking for questions if
you have some questions please use the
Q
Button to ask me
things I'm in the last part of the last
part
and I hope this presentation has been
useful Well now what I want to
let you know I would like to think that after
that  presentation everyone who is
using monitoring monitoring program are going
to review it are going to see if you can
change it if you can improve it using
some new
technologies remembering what
we want is useful results that is
profitable and that would be our
optimal monitoring program thank you for your attention I'm going  Let's see
if there are some
questions
Ah
well I have several people
who have posted congratulations well
Thank you very much for that good evening
everyone let's see if
I can I still don't see
questions Okay here I have
one That's from someone in Mexico Good
evening ah several
questions the person asks  If you
consider that a good sentinel could
be an animal from the same
strain. Oh, we
certainly use Sentinels from the
same strain. When we do the ration to
prove that the animals
from the embryo transfer are
free of infections. So yes, it is very
good, obviously,
if it is from  the same know is a sample
only from the same
animals also the other thing is
that it has to be an animal that has a
normal
immune system capacity to see what else why do
you think that the monit followed by the same
same colony with
different results  I'm not sure if I understand
that question The question is why do
you think that in consecutive monitoring of the
same Colony there are
different results well I guess There are so many
reasons why it is a very
good one sometimes there are problems in the
laboratory and I have had in serology
False positives occur from time to time
so what I do in
this case is Generally take
new samples and send them again certainly
with surgery if one is not very
careful How the blood is taken
if there is hemolysis in the sample
that will impact  in surgery and many
times that is the reason for
false positive results that can be the origin of the
difference sometimes it can be that not
all animals are infected and
one has to remember that in a
colony there is a percentage of animals
Generally that  They are going to be
infected. I hope that answers your
question.
Oh, I have someone who asks from
Bolivia. How many viruses or parasites
should you include in your
program? I guess. That is the point of
my presentation.
I think that in each vivarium you have to
take into
account the type of  vivarium the types
of animals Obviously the cost is going to
impact a lot So the number of
pathogens that one includes is going to depend
on all these factors I think that
all the problems the
monoo programs should be dealt with
individually that's what I think
Ah  someone asked if it is possible
to deliver my email and Ah The
answer is yes Ah if anyone wants my
email I will post it in a
moment Ah I will return to that another
question with consider that there is an
ideal sentinel to use in all
cpas
Uh
Look, for me the ideal sentinel would be a
cohabitant for all the reasons I
mentioned before and generally that is
possible because it has different sexes Oh it
would be an animal I would generally use
an out Bread because
they have good
immune responses I generally place
young animals because we are more
susceptible to
infections  But if I have a resurgence
of a specific infection, a
specific pathogen, there are quite a few articles now
that show that some
mouse trins have better
immune responses to certain pathogens,
so we just had a problem with
Bars and the fbn strin was ideal as a
sentinel in this  case
We generally use a Swiss I hope that
answers your
question Oh there is another person who wants
my email so what I'm going to
do is put it I wait
here I
don't wait I have a technical problem Here
I'm going to close
this and
see Sorry sorry I have a
technological problem here  in place I thought I
could write here I'm going to answer it
myself in the qa
Ah the
email Okay I'm going to answer my email is
j k i n g h a m
a G e a r d a n d period o
RG
Au
Ah answer
one ah I'm going to answer another one it seems
that there is that's the end of the questions
so I'm putting my email here
Ah that's the end of the
questions again Thank you very much
for your attention I hope you excuse
my Spanish a little I hope it wasn't
too difficult to understand And that would be
all thank you very much
everyone